good evening and welcome to fox news
prime time
yesterday i came to you to talk about
the 1970s how much they resemble our
challenge today
and how they are different tonight i
want to go back a little further in our
history
60 years ago last week in a rare midday
joint session on capitol hill
president john f kennedy set an
incredible goal for the nation
he announced to the congress that i
believe that this nation
should commit itself to achieving the
goal before this decade is out
of landing a man on the moon and
returning him safely to earth
no single space project in this period
will be more impressive to mankind
or more important for the long-range
exploration of space
and none will be so difficult or
expensive to accomplish
but in a very real sense it will not be
one man going to the moon
we make this judgment affirmatively it
will be an entire nation
for all of us must work to put him there
it's worth your time to watch the speech
and not just to laugh at lbj
working so hard to make sure he's in
every frame at times he looks like he's
ready to climb into sam rayburn's lap
it seems like it comes not just from a
different time but from a different
country
in his call for a project of immense
national import president kennedy comes
across
as the leader of a free people
committing us to a clear-eyed task
of achieving something that seemed
utterly impossible
he has none of the lecturing attitude of
philosopher king wannabe barack obama
the bombast of a reality show star like
donald trump or the weary old man shakes
fist at cloud energy of joe biden
instead of patronizing the audience he
walks americans through a challenge with
clear language
to explain why it's important in the
tokvillian sense
he speaks to us as citizens not subjects
kennedy called us to undertake the
moonshot as a free people for the good
of all mankind
such a national mega project commitment
with a nine year horizon
is basically unthinkable today the
politics of the 1960s allowed for it
but those of today do not to grasp how
significant this project was
consider this passage from buck mr
fuller the critical path organization of
the apollo project
disclosed some two million tasks that
had to be successfully accomplished
before the human astronauts were to be
returned safely to spaceship earth
nasa's apollo management then put a
scientifically and technically competent
control group
to work to identify all approximately
two million tasks
a million of which acquired
technological performances the design
production and successful operation of
which had never before
been undertaken by humans this isn't
just a president taking on a risky aim
he's taking on an impossible aim or one
that would today seem impossible
involving a million new tasks never
before achieved
keep in mind this was in the midst of a
cold war we thought we were losing
americans were dispirited troops had
just entered vietnam to fight the
chinese
the soviets had beaten us into space
with sputnik and with the first man in
space
china had fallen to mao cuba had fallen
just a few years after that
our u2 had been shot down over russia
the president gave
this audacious speech less than two
months after the bay of pigs
the enemy had the bomb americans were
afraid of a nuclear holocaust
but jfk understood america needed
this win for a president to give such a
speech today
every turn would emphasize the needs of
a particular constituency
assuring people that the contractor jobs
building rockets
would be good paying union jobs that
hiring would be done based on historical
equity not
racist math and that of course will get
all the necessary permissions from the
united nations the eu and the who
about the health and environmental
ramifications of rocket fumes
and of course the speech would be picked
apart as sacrificing science
on the altar of cold war political
victories the press would denounce it
why not spend that money on the ground
on people who need it
instead of some far-fetched vision of
putting a man on the moon
they'd call it propaganda instead of
idealism and they'd probably be quoting
anonymous sources from inside nasa
disputing the president's aim is
foolhardy from larry schweikert's
and michael allen's a patriots history
of the united states newly released
tapes from the kennedy library of a key
1962 discussion
with nasa administrator james webb
revealed that webb repeatedly resisted
kennedy's efforts to turn the u.s space
program into a narrowly focused lunar
expedition
jfk wanted a propaganda victory pure and
simple
everything we do in space he said ought
to be tied into getting to the moon
ahead of the russians
he then laid it on the table for the
nasa administrator saying that beating
the russians the moon
is the top priority of the space agency
and except for defense
the top priority of the united states
government
there's another another troublesome
aspect to consider here
the apollo mega project was primarily a
civilian operation
with the exception of the astronauts
themselves who were drawn mostly from
the military
today such an undertaking would almost
certainly be handed to the
armed forces with a flag officer placed
in charge
see for example the use of generals for
running operation warp speed
our generals are good at everything
these days it seems but winning wars
what does that say about the state of
the republic one where our trust for
every major institution
with the exception of the military has
decayed beyond the point of usefulness
in audacious endeavors while nasa still
serves an important function
the private sector has taken over the
true moonshot engineering tasks
but it's worth remembering what was
supposed to happen following the
fulfillment of kennedy's vision
and what happened instead you see apollo
was supposed to be a beginning
not an end nasa's space task group by
1969
envisioned the first phase of apollo
setting up permanent shelters on the
moon
by 1973. permanent lunar habitation
likely with supporting space station
infrastructure was envisioned by 1980
a mars expedition building on the lunar
experience was slated for 1983.
instead of this steady american progress
toward colonizing the solar system
the final three apollo missions were
scrubbed instead
we spent the money on low earth orbit
missions where we've stayed for most of
the past half century
those missions are of course not without
risk my first memory a searing one
familiar to so many children of the 80s
is the challenger explosion but that is
not the reason
we go to space it is not the highest
mountain
it's not lindbergh crossing the atlantic
and it's not why rice plays texas
we are meant to push farther to sail for
further shores than this
gives me great pride as an american that
in 296
000 years when voyager 2 slides by the
binary syria system
the brightest star in the sky and is
cracked open by their giant
rotating blocks of ice in the darkness
of space
its onboard system will play the golden
record contained inside
and if anyone's around to hear the sound
they won't just hear beethoven
or mozart or bach no any species who can
hear will hear who we were
the americans the brash wilderness
people
who hurled this primitive rocket beyond
the limits of our solar system
to reach out into the stars they will
hear the opening riff
of chuck berry's johnny be good perhaps
the best lesson to take away from this
historical anniversary then
is less about what america has lost in
our institutions or
our ambitions over the past 60 years and
more
what could be regained with a return to
a form of leadership
that tolerates and accepts political
risk as part of what is demanded of them
risk is not something we handle well as
americans these days
a pandemic surely proved that point
better than anything else could
but it's not just fear in the face of
disease we live in a country where
teenagers don't want to get driver's
licenses
where our schools can't fail kids for
giving the wrong answers
where teachers refuse to teach even with
precautions and vaccinations
and where local authorities won't put
down riots
jfk called the nation to dare men died
as a result
we pushed forward it's one thing for a
single daredevil or even 20 to take on
such a risk
it's a lot more for a country to do so
in kennedy's framing 60 years ago
our common identity as americans is what
unites us
rather than stoke the divisions of race
or class he focused our energies toward
an incredible goal
rather than a series of apologies and
hand-wringing over the sins of the past
or any lack of clarity about our foe in
the soviets
kennedy's message was that unity in our
american ethos
can launch us to the stars the american
spirit is still there
it still beats in the heart of this
great nation
but we need to honor it and unite around
it again
and that will require more than just a
fine speech from a politician
it will require something of you as well
it will require you to wake up
i'm ben dominic and this is the american
crisis
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis
you will not get it anywhere else